hey I need to prepare you for something
that we're starting to see crafted by
right-wing media about Trump Russia
collusion more and more conservatives
are laying the groundwork for defending
Donald Trump's collusion with Russia by
saying hey you know what
even if Trump colluded with Russia it
wouldn't be a crime anyway so here's how
it's gone it's amazing how these things
develop that before it was 100% didn't
happen no Trump collusion with Russia no
coordination didn't happen Russia not
involved period now as it becomes more
and more difficult to deny Russia's
involvement and to deny the fact that if
Trump associates didn't collude with
Russia they're being pretty damn sketchy
by constantly lying about the contacts
that they've had with Russia now that
it's pointing in that direction you're
seeing more and more people in
right-wing media shift to well if there
was collusion between Trump and Russia
it wouldn't be a crime anyway and this
is a pre-emptive attempt to defuse what
we might be on the brink of learning
here pad one example over the weekend on
the show Fox News Sunday conservative
commentator Brit Hume started saying hey
listen after all if Trump colluded with
Russia it wouldn't be a crime it
wouldn't be appropriate but it wouldn't
be a crime here's Brit Hume what what
crime right anybody identify the crime
collusion well as obviously alarming and
highly inappropriate for the Trump
campaign of which there's no evidence by
the way of colluding with the Russians
it's not a crime not a crime well who
cares if he colluded Hannity same thing
on Fox News earlier that day Geraldo
Rivera has recently tried to make this
point conservative columnist Ronald
Kessler recently tried to make this
point this is an absurd talking point
but it does signal a significant shift
which is before it was deny deny deny
now it's say hey who cares it's not even
really that big of a deal and certainly
now is the time to test out that talking
point it's like you're throwing a bunch
of things at the wall I'm seeing what
will stick yep I think for the Fox News
audience this is going to work and
there's two responses here right one is
we'll hold on a second it's not just
about collusion at this point I'll get
back to that in a second the other
responses campaign law experts say that
actually there's many laws that could be
applied to Trump collusion with Russia
campaign finance laws may have been
violated communications laws may have
been violated a large number of laws
pertaining to treason as well as the
Espionage Act as well as the Logan Act
the public hardly knows anything about
those laws nor about what the FBI and
congressional investigations are turning
up if there is evidence of collusion we
don't know about it yet and this is
clearly starting to lay the groundwork
for the if and or' when we find out
about that and conservatives are trying
to prime the public for eventually
having evidence of that collusion and
being able to write it off as not
breaking the law that's not true but
here's the second issue we're well
beyond just collusion right collusion is
not the only issue on the table at this
point it's arguably not even the biggest
issue on the table we are now talking
about obstruction of justice and we've
been talking about that from a number of
different angles over the last month or
six weeks as well as the cover-up
attempt on this and very often it's not
the initial crime it's the cover-up and
if the collusion was the initial we
won't call it a crime right now but
we'll call it a transgression we've got
way more now than just the collusion
it's the cover-up and the obstruction so
this floating of a talking point it
actually may work as will many of these
manipulation techniques on trumpets but
it's a drastic distortion of reality and
let's take a look at three of the
charges levied against Richard Nixon
during the Watergate scandal by the
House Judiciary Committee yeah one
obstruction of justice to abuse of power
and three contempt of Congress right
when you have Trump floating the idea of
tapes and maybe there are maybe there
are and maybe he's not giving them over
to Congress when he's not releasing his
tax returns when he's firing the people
in charge of investigating him I think
those could count for all three of those
things indeed and individually and this
is where you're you're building a case
right individually firing person a that
is not a crime not releasing your tax
returns also not a crime it's something
done by tradition not not a crime by any
means but if it all fits into the an
attempt to cover up and obstruct finding
out the truth about Trump's connect
that's where it can be become part of
one of these cases and by the way during
the same show on Fox News Brit Hume
talked about how the FBI is democratic
partisans here he's doing something else
which is he's priming people to
disregard the eventual findings of the
investigation he's basically saying
listen if we do at some points he's
so-called evidence of collusion number
one its Democratic partisans at the FBI
anyway so maybe it's not trustworthy and
number two it's not even necessarily a
crime to collude with Russia this is
what we call priming the audience and
they're doing it over at Fox News I
think some would call it hyperbolic to
say that Trump's campaign colluding with
the Russians would be treasonous but not
so much because if you're doing the
bidding of another country and
undermining our own sovereignty I think
that fits the definition pretty athlete
particularly when you're campaigning on
the idea that you're going to be all
about America first which would be a
flat-out joke you don't do this unless
you're worried you don't change approach
on something so significant if you're
not at least slightly worried about
what's going on and we we are already
starting to learn about what the
defenses will be from Trump is can't
trust the FBI anyway collusion is not
illegal anyway talk about this on our
reddit discussion forum okay we are
there at david pakman.com slash our IDI
di t today's program is made possible in
part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com /t DPS